[Music]
dates on food guide us when we go
shopping
but many people are confused about what
use by and best before mean
one indicates the last day a product is
safe to eat
the other that the food can be consumed
but is past its best
as part of the farm to fork strategy the
european commission is looking into new
date marking rules
less than half of consumers understand
the difference between used by and best
before this has very tangible
consequences 10 of europe's food waste
is due to a lack of understanding of
date marking
we check out how major retailers and
consumer organizations are dealing with
this
[Music]
test asha the oldest consumer
association in belgium points out that
sometimes both best before and used by
are used on the same kind of products
this can be misleading
as a consumer when you see these two
products that look similar
and you see that they use different date
markers it obviously adds confusion
you wonder why one is considered highly
perishable and not the other
in reality this is a second issue that
adds to the confusion
how date marking is managed by food
business operators along the supply
chain can also have an impact on food
waste
here products pass their best before
date are being sold at a lower price
given to charities or even used to
produce energy through natural processes
we lower the price of products that are
close to their use by date with yellow
promotional labels
then we give the products that don't
sell to charities and then they'll be
distributed to people who need them
the products that are unfit for
consumption are also recycled and made
into green energy
to improve the understanding and use of
date marking for everyone the european
commission has launched an impact study
and requested scientific advice from the
european food safety authority
consumer organizations like the belgian
test asha want to join the initiative
[Music]
we're very happy that the european
commission is taking up this issue
an impact study has been carried out and
there will be a public consultation
which we will obviously take part in
the idea is to follow as closely as
possible any proposals that will be put
on the table to be sure that they meet
consumer expectations in terms of
clarity and understanding
let's head to france to discover an
initiative helping to reduce food waste
too good to go is an app that connects
consumers with restaurants and shops
where you can buy unsold food for less
the company also launched a campaign
with several major brands
its goal is to encourage people to use
their senses when considering food and
the best before date
[Music]
we've worked with producers on labels to
create icons that encourage consumers to
trust their senses
the icons represent the sense of sight
smell and taste and are on products with
a best before date
it makes the date more understandable
and helps consumers trust their senses
before throwing away a product that is
past its best before date
ensuring better labeling and helping
consumers make sustainable food choices
are part of the farmed fork strategy
action plan the european commission aims
to present a new set of rules on date
marking by the end of 2022
[Music]